[موسيقى]
صاحبه وسريعه تلك الساعات التي قضاها محمد
عقب الانفجار كان هنا في محله لحظه وقوع
الهجوم
يرينا في هذا التسجيل الذي صوره احد
زملائه من من اصيبوا وهو ملقا على الارض
قبل ان يشرعه هو في مساعده فرق الان
كل شيء حدث بسرعه ما زالت الاصوات
اذكر منظر الطفله ووالدها
على بعد امتار فقط
الحزن يعلو وجوه من حضروا الى مكان سقوط
القتلى
بعضهم جاء للتعبير عن تضامنه مع اهالي
الضحايا مسؤولون اتراك حضروا الى هنا
لاعلان عزم الدوله التركيه على ردع ما
وصفوه بمحاولات زعزعه الاستقرار
اقول لكم
من يستهدفون امن تركيا تستمر
حتى وان كان اثر الهجوم وما خلفه من
ضحاياه
سيبقى محفورا في الوجدان
اقصى العقوبات بالجنيه الذين حددتهم
السلطات بانهم من وحدات حمايه الشعب الامر
الذي قد يعيد الحديث مره اخرى عن عمليه
عسكريه مرتقبه في سوريا اسطنبول